hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game between vasily von Schuch and
manuel Petrosyan it's a game from the
round 8 of the Sun way serious
tournament you know that very nice place
that's being played here you know the
one with with the photo too big to be
shown in its entirety so I have to use
my special dragging effects to show it
there you have it for those of you who
might have missed a game from round one
of the Sun we see this tournament were
well-well wear it once you had a pretty
rough start to the tournament who was
that very nice brilliancy but now we
have a completely different game it's a
really weird game but it's a weird for
different reasons but before we start to
enjoy this game like I said I really
hope you're having a wonderful Saturday
and here we have a very nice image that
was sent to me via email by mr. sander
an excellent subscriber who made this
it's basically Bobby Fischer who is
Santa Claus I'm the elf behind him the
little helper and the meadow is
obviously the reindeer that well pulls
the sleigh so thank you for that it's
quite quite the imagination very vivid I
really like it
so thank you for that and now let's
check out this very nice game so if I
shook has the white pieces and we
already have well not your everyday
opening efore c6 the caro-kann d4 d5 and
now f3 the marathi variation of the kora
con most likely event she wants to take
his a young adversary out of book as
soon as possible so already on a move
three maybe I forgot to mention Manuel
Petrosyan is a 20 year old Armenian
Grandmaster who in 2016 one be under 18
World Youth Championships so basically
he is a world champion and taking on
vastly von Schuch is it can always be a
really a wonderful journey you never
know what to expect you can like it
right in round one where event will lose
in 25 moves but sometimes event you will
beat Magnus Carlsen twice in one
tournament so you never really know what
what you're getting here but okay yeah
six getting further further control of
the d5 square we have Knight to c3 and
now Bishop to b4 pinning the knight on
c3 Bishop to f4 and this was all played
before this this is all pretty much
standard theory Knight to f6 and now
Queen to d3 further protecting d4 pawn
but also preparing to Castle queenside
we have b6 castling queenside Bishop to
e6 attacking the Queen Queen to e3 and
now Bishop captures on f1 rook captures
on f1 and now we have castles Knight G
to E - of course you do have to keep on
developing and the knight is also
protected here so if captures you can
even capture with the night and here we
have c5 black now feels very competent
in his development and he attacks even
took center and it's very interesting
this exact same position was reached -
once in 2005 between with the white
pieces there was a Eric Soaring who is a
who's an unrated player back then so
it's interesting that vasily von Schuch
who was the one's the number-two rated
player in the world and also he even
today he's a top top rated Grandmaster
finds himself in a position like this
that was already played by an unrated
player but okay in that game g4 was
played and black won that game but here
Asli goes for ecad force on d5 and
already we have a lot of interesting
development we have Bishop captures on
c3 Knight captures on c3 Knight captures
on d5 and already we have a well maybe
not a critical but a very important
moment in the game here it seems like
you have to capture for example if you
play Knight captures here you get Queen
captures and now to prevent losing at
this point because the a to pawn is also
under attack you would have to give up
be a two point first you will capture
here then after black captures be a two
point you will go Queen to a3 not allow
any checks and then black will either
trade Queens but most likely go back
let's say Queen to c4 Bishop b3
defending the c5 pawn and the game
continues but the blacks position
we'll be better if I do doesn't like
this so instead of going night captures
on d5
it might replace Queen to e4 and it
seems like a very nice idea the night
cannot capture because the rook on a H
is hanging and here the young
Grandmaster Manuel Petrosyan believed a
bunch of debt it is impossible to play
Knight captures on c3 and play Knight to
c6 but Knight captures on c3 was in fact
the best move
you cannot capture the rope here because
of nicely to check and you lose the
bishop as well King moves Knight
captures on f4 and now you will have two
nights for a rook black will have a
winning I mean a winning game here and
on the other hand after Knight chapters
in c3 since you can't capture the rook
you could play the B captures in c3 this
would be best but then comes nice to d7
the rope is protected the see the c5
pawn is protected and black is just
having a better game so this was the
correct way to go but okay we have Queen
to b4 and now Knight to c6
as we've said D captures on c5 by man
choke now comes Knight captures on c3
you cannot capture here because of the
same idea nice to eat to check picks up
the bishop so we have to capture the
knight be captures on c3 and now we have
Queen to f6 offering the c6 Knight for
the bishop on f4 of course the bishop on
f4 is a much more valuable piece so
first King to be to protecting the c3
pawn and but also the King will be much
safer there
and now comes B captures on c5 and when
you look at this position the Queen I'm
the King there on b2 the night is very
dangerously placed perhaps the rook can
come to b8 maybe even with a sacrifice
but eventually says no not really and he
plays rook to b1 and now even with
Evancho's awkward position of the
kingdom b2 you can see that it's
actually a von Schuch who controls the B
file and well if his position is not all
that bad so okay rook a to d8 the going
for check here doesn't really do
anything so first look a to d8 and now
comes look H to d1 challenging the rook
on the open D file and now comes Luke to
b5 and here even check has a
you can either trade it down or continue
playing in it in a different fashion if
you go rogue characters on d5 you go
into this fourth line eke after Sun d5
Queen captures Queen captures on it for
Queen captures on c6 and now rook the be
a check and now I have to king to a-1
you will either have to go back with the
rook because if you trade then you get
King captures you have some background
weaknesses you have to fix those g6 g3
and you can see that white will have a
better game he's up a pawn and well you
know being being up a pawn in a Queen's
endgame usually is a pretty huge
advantage so it's hard to save this
would be winning for white but event you
would have definitely have good chances
but as you don't have to trade the final
rook it's hard to say that the white
would actually have winning chances so
after work the d5 inventive tries to
complicate things we have rope to d3 and
now comes Rock captures on d3c captures
on d3 and not nice to be for pressuring
the d3 pawn as the c3 pawn is pinned the
Queen is pinning it from f6 Bishop back
to d2 not allowing bishop here to stay a
target and now comes Luke to d8 now
again push putting pressure on the on
this pawn and now comes d4 now with d4
being played the c3 pawn is no longer
pin so C characters on b4 is now a
threat and here Petrosyan could go back
Knight to d5 but he doesn't here he
plays h6 makes some breathing room for
King reducing the back ranked weaknesses
and eventually goes for it we have C
captures on b4 so Petrosyan sacrifice is
a piece but what's what's the
compensation well of course rook
captures on d4 and if you look at this
position it seems okay the Queen is
under attack you have to move the Queen
once you make a move I'm gonna make some
sort of a nasty it in this nasty
discovery and well white white will be
lost of course and here it's interesting
what we want to plan we have Queen to a8
check and now black has to make a move
so now if you put yourself in Young
Petrosyan shoes here he's playing up
against Vasiliev on choke and you
think why would he allow rope to d8 the
wither discover check so let's see what
happens here
rook to b8 now discovering a check
against the white king but also
attacking the Queen so here if I don't
you had Bishop to c3 in mind and now
after Queen captures on c3 with check
King captures pawn captures and b4 with
check rook captures now you pick up the
Queen and you are left with this
position where white is up upon and well
however you put it you can always at
least have a draw but for some reason
Petrosyan did not like this he didn't go
for this rook to d8 block blocking check
and delivering a discovery check but
rather he played King to h7 and here if
I should immediately ran away with the
King King to c1 and now there are no
more discoveries here but Queen to g6 a
very precise move preparing well there
are some threats like rook captures here
and then picking up the rook can be won
but a greater threat is simply Roxy for
check and picking up the row can be won
so if I prevents it we have looked to be
- now there is no threat of actually
picking up the rule can be won but also
here we have a completely critical
moment where black sacrificed material
he's down down a piece and he has to
make it count
so here Petrosyan played Queen captures
in g2 which is a mistake it doesn't
allow black to go for anything anymore
but there was one more move that allowed
black to push for the win so feel free
to pause the video you are at home
having a very nice Saturday if you are
like me you know not going out just you
know staying at home so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the well
let's say the winning idea for black for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are truly an
excellent player as both the young
Grandmaster from Armenia in mono pitocin
and the great Vasily von Schuch have
missed this and for those who just want
to enjoyed show the move is rook to c4
check now what happens here obviously
you cannot
check due to Queen kept Queen to c2
checkmate but what else can you do you
can't go to be one the queen is covering
be one you have to go King d1 and now
comes Queen captures and g2 most likely
both of them saw this but it's very hard
to figure out what happens next
the problem is if you allow Queen
captures on f3 in in any variation then
black is winning for example you want to
bring the Queen into the game maybe
bring more defense to the bishop here
then if you allow Queen captures on f3
you're getting checkmated pink has to
move then rook check here the four
blocks captures and Queen captures this
will be checkmate
but the really cool stuff happens if you
don't move the Queen after this Queen
captures in g2
let's say you go Bishop to c3 now you
open a discovered attack against the
black Queen you get Queen to f1 check
King moves now comes rope to f4 again
threatening to capture on f3 Queen to a
fate not white threatens checkmate on g7
f6 blocking checkmate and now Queen
captures on c5 the Queen now joins the
defense rook to a5 attacking the Queen
the Queen has to move with Queen here
and now comes rope the d5 check at the
pond from e6 is guarding the rook and
now well you will either move let's say
Kings king c2 and then Queen to d1
delivers checkmate as the King cannot go
to B 2 or C 3 or if the King goes
perhaps the e3 then you get rook to d3
check King to f4 and now Queen to c1
check Queen has a king has to go to g3
and now you can either recapture on c3
but you can also just improve the
position you can go f5
prepare f4 as the Queen is also
controlling f4 and there really is no
way for black to for life to escape
death here
black will either checkmate the white
king black can always really capture
this extra piece for example if you try
to defend it then Queen g1 leads to
leads to checkmate King h3 and now of
course you can all see mate in one
it's a very nice checkmate Queen g4 as
the f3 pawn is pinned the rook is
pinning it so this would be a very nice
checkmate so a lot of a lot of possible
waste to
here for black but well perhaps chalky
saw it and he bluffed his way out of it
but Manolo petrosyan definitely didn't
see it so rook the c4 would have been
winning here but first he played a queen
capture Sanji - now similar ideas are
possible here but event you goes rook to
c2 now rook the c4 is no longer possible
and now it's actually white that has a
better position here you don't want to
allow any bishop to see three ideas that
could be very very dangerous so first
see capture some before and now comes
Queen captures on a7 attacking the rook
on d4 rook to d3 and now Bishop captures
on before so now even Chuck has is up a
bishop and has a past
a pawn we have Queen to f1 check King
moves and now rook captures on f3
Petrosyan is up two pawns but still at
two points against a piece and the past
pawn it's not going going to be easy so
this position is winning for eventual
and now it's merely a matter of
technique Queen c5 we have looked to f4
now a3 protecting the bishop on b4 Queen
to h1 and now comes look to have two
offering the trade of rooks we have E 5
but event might we have captures
captures and now you don't want to allow
f3 so the black passed pawn can keep on
moving we have Queen - fi with check
King moves and now not recapturing the
pawn but first event you like an
experienced man that he is
first repeats the position a couple of
times to reach time control a little bit
faster Queen ch-check King h7 of Quintus
f5 check King g8 and only now does
Chuckie recapture on f4 Queen captures
on i-4 and now comes g5 black is now
trying to pull the pass bones as well
well that's not a passed pawn but you
know still you do want to push them
Queen e5 Queen - b7 trying something but
it's not not at all clear what you are
trying King to h7 Queen to f5 check and
docking to g7
we have a for a f6 now and now a5 even
just simply keeps on pushing his past
pawn that's the clearest way to victory
Queen to f7 with check King moves we
have Queen to be seven back and now King
to a3 we have Queen the c7 but now a six
Queen to c6 attacking the pawn but now a
seven and now comes a series of checks
we have Queen to c1
sorry about that King to be three Queen
to d1 with check King Queen to c2
blocking now comes Queen to f3 and now
Queen to c3 uh uh uh a lot of you
probably had this happen to a lot in
your own games especially in serious
tournament games where you sacrifice a
piece perhaps you have a very strong
attack perhaps even a winning attack
perhaps the patron was considering that
rook to see for mu but then he didn't
play it he wanted to improve the
position with Queen captures and you do
a bit and then his attack just
evaporated and now he wants to try
everything you know the perhaps creates
something Queen to e3 point d5 check
King moves Queen to c6 we have Queen to
c5 Queen to f3 with check King f4 King
g6 now black is also making some
progress
the queen is preventing the pawn to be
Queen as the queen is guarding the H
square but it's it's very hard Queen to
c8 preparing pawn to eight now comes
Queen to d1 with check King b5 and now
Queen to defy with chair Bishop to c5
Queen b3 check King c6 Queen to f3 check
so perhaps if black can simply continue
checking on the white king maybe there
could be you know I draw by perpetual
checking but it is very unlikely King c7
we have Queen to d5 now at least if you
if you bring a queen into the game then
you can capture on c5 but first we have
Queen to d8 a queen to eight with check
and it was in this position that mana
Petrosyan resigned the game you can
either go to the bank rank or you can go
to f5 whichever you play hello taking h7
Queen d7 check
traits queens and then the a pawn is
winning or if you go to a five it's the
same idea Queen d7 checked rates queens
and it's all over then a queen wins the
game so a very nice victory for eventual
who had a rough start to the tournament
now this is uh this is yeah this was
around eight and now he I think he has a
six and a half points out of eight and
he is tied for first with I think with
Ernesto enough Kiev and one more one
more player can't really remember but I
know that today he's playing against
them Esther in Turkey have you you
remember an Estonian or Kiev when he
when he tried that double illegal move
tactic against magnus carlsen in the in
the world with championship if you
haven't seen that game I do have a video
on it so you can check it out it will be
the first thing you see in the
description below also a very nice game
but yeah a very nice victory for revenge
okay and I'm very good to see how he is
today's game will go so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank John Flynn Darian schnell
Mon on rescue John Mullen and Sean
wilcoxon for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it which this contribution
Sean Wilcox and once again joins the
team as the top contributor I think I
think she donated already before last
year's Christmas becoming the top
contributor so very glad to see that you
are enjoying the content still enjoying
the content Sam once again we can check
out this very nice image of Bobby
Fischer myself and the meadow there we
have it once again as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
all for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon